over the weekend Jeff Bezos is personal
newspaper ran a fawning profile of a
Georgia politician called Stacey Abrams
now by itself that's not very surprising
Abrams is a well-known left-wing
Democrat and the Washington Post exists
to promote people like that for decades
it often has but even by the usual
standards of over-the-top slobbering
hackery this piece exists in its own
category by the end of the nearly 6,000
words of unmitigated praise you began to
wonder why no one has yet formed a
religion based on Stacey Abrams the
world's fourth great Abrahamic faith
according to the Washington Post Abrams
is a lot more than just a former state
elected official who goes on cable
television a lot
she's a spiritual figure indeed she is
quite possibly the author of our
Redemption listen to how the thoroughly
smitten Post reporter describes an
encounter between Stacey Abrams and her
devoted acolytes and keep in mind as you
hear this that we're not making any of
it up to be mean this is verbatim quote
pandemonium ensues as she walks to the
far left of the stage like a runway
supermodel stops on a dime poses tilts
her head slightly and smiles camera
flashes explode Abrams is summoning her
inner actress and she's both enjoying
the moment and getting through it to get
to the conversation end quote so she's
like a supermodel
but she's also a superhero in fact the
piece was entitled the power of Stacey
Abrams in the accompanying photo Abrams
poses like Superman cape trailing behind
her just in case you missed the point of
the piece this woman is going to save
the world and Washington Post thinks
that's possible the story was designed
of course to push Joe Biden to pick
Stacey Abrams as his running mate now no
one who knows Biden or who watches him
carefully thinks he could lead this
country in his condition or even serve a
full term in a ceremonial role as
president anyone who serves as vice
president under Joe Biden would in
effect be President of the United States
all of which raises the obvious question
who exactly is this Stacey Abrams
they're relentlessly promoting what for
example does she
for a living probably the first question
and as it turns out not much
supposedly Abrams runs some kind of
political action committee paid for by
Mike Bloomberg Joseph serves on a few
boards all in all it's not a heavy-lift
job wise Abrams actual vocation is being
professionally aggrieved that's a real
job
three years ago Abrams served in the
Georgia State House that's a real job
it's still in fact the highest office
she has ever held in the Georgia State
House while she was there she
accomplished let's see virtually nothing
we checked 2016 she did get some
publicity for sponsoring a bill that
would have ordered police to seize by
force also called assault weapons in the
state the same bill would have made it a
felony to possess what she called a
high-capacity magazine and once again
the police would have been obliged to
seize those by force she did that and
that's about it why do we know her name
well because in 2018 stacey abrams lost
the georgia governor's race and was not
despite what they tell you in especially
close election she came up short by
55,000 votes as nearly half a percent
and this was a cycle with the state's
highest voter turnout in decades and she
still lost by 55,000 votes
how did Abrams respond well she
pretended it never happened
she declare herself governor anyway and
she denounced anyone who disagreed with
that as a racist well instead of calling
the state mental health authorities as
they might have done many of her fellow
Democrats played along with the fantasy
without voter suppression Stacey Abrams
would be the governor of Georgia
if this country wasn't racist stacy
abrams would be governor
it was the voter suppression
particularly of african-american
communities that prevented us from
having a governor Stacey Abrams right
math Stacey Abrams ought to be the
governor of Georgia when racially
motivated voter suppression is permitted
we cannot truly say that we live in a
democracy this country wasn't racist
Stacey Abrams would be governor by the
way as a factual matter there's
literally zero evidence to support that
that's true or even sort of true doesn't
matter the fact that Stacey Abrams isn't
the governor of Georgia despite losing a
fair election with the highest voter
turnout in decades can only be racism
that is Stacey Abrams his position in
fact she's making the same case to get
herself selected as the vice
presidential nominee if Joe Biden
doesn't choose Stacey Abrams he's racist
do you think that not choosing a woman
of color a black woman actually is a
slap in the face to the black female
voters I would share your concern about
not picking a woman of color because
women of color particularly black women
are the strongest part of the Democratic
Party
we need a ticket that reflects the
diversity of America yeah you need a
ticket with Stacey Abrams on it that's
what you need mister racist guy so say
what you will about Stacey Abrams she's
not so there's no mistaking her motives
or her meanings give her what she wants
or she will call you racist it's simple
another word for that tactic is identity
politics and of course Abrams is for
that too probably
[Music]
[Applause]
quote identity politics are the only
politics that win end quote
where did abrams learn that cynical
little slogan probably Yale Law School
where like so many oppressed political
figures before her of course she went
well Joe Biden fall for this yet
probably he's weak and confused and
desperate to make the in-group the cool
kids but should the rest of us fall for
it is not being called racist worth
having Stacey Abrams from the country
that's really the question